ein ganz normales in weimar heißt es
jetzt umgewöhnen döner das war einmal
der rechtlich einwandfreie begriff für
dieses beliebte fladenbrot mit fleisch
und salat lauteten drehspieß keine
widerrede
es ist einfach ungewohnt also bin ich
nicht mit döner ja also was ist
drehspieß das kann auch was süßes sein
dass an dem dreh spiels kann auch ein
karussell länge noch oder
zuckerkristalle aber es hat was sehr
witziges es ist ganz schön spitzfindig
also es klingt nicht nach was leckeres
zu essen dann vielleicht eher nach einer
waffe eigentlich wollte man die
verbraucher nicht verwirren sondern
schützen
denn laut deutschen lebensmittelbuch
muss echtes dönerfleisch genaue
qualitätsvorgaben erfüllen nur grob
entziehen des schafs oder rindfleisch
ein hackfleisch anteil von maximal 60
prozent salz und gewürze eventuell noch
ein zivilen öl milch und joghurt wie bei
den meisten töne im wissen kommt aber
auch hier das fleisch vom großhändler
und dort ist die rezeptur eben oft ein
bisschen anders als die vorschrift mit
der folge wo kein original dönerfleisch
drin ist darf auch nicht döner
draufstehen so einfach sind die regeln
wir mussten die flyer rindern sich
taufen mussten wir schon ändern also wir
haben die ganzen im walldürner
draufstand haben wir umgesetzt haben auf
dem spieß um geändert und es wurde so
vorgeschrieben von der stadt und das
muss auch gemacht haben für das wort
drehspieß gibt es keine vorgaben
allerdings fließt den meisten kunden bei
diesem begriff bislang auch noch nicht
das wasser im mund zusammen ist ein
sperriges wort sagt sich leicht beim
bestellen
ich hätte gern döner und ein drehspieß
klingt sehr deutsch
so würde ich es ausdrücken denn dann
besteht ja nicht nur aus dem fleisch der
am drehspieß ist es ist ja mehr es ist
ja nicht nur das fleisch ist das gemuese
und weil sie zwiebeln und die saucen
nicht zu vergessen das ist ja ein
gesamtkonzept das geht nicht nur um den
spieß ist lächerlich
aber auf diese art mal wieder von den
problemen ablenken die wirklich gelöst
werden müssten
der gut gemeinte schutz vor irreführung
für die meisten fleischliebhaber am ende
eher ein
ich denke mal wir werden noch lange
thema sagen du hast schöne also der
punkt hätte ich schenke dir genau wie
vorher oder ob döner drehspieß oder ganz
was anderes hauptsache es macht satt